hey guys i'm ryan right so today i'm
gonna be checking out the ant-man
official clip number one just saw this
on movieclips trailers and sure enough i
got blown up the wazoo with request
requests going straight into my bumhole
making me have rectal dysfunction let's
do this
[Music]
bien
[Music]
whoa that was pretty crazy cool shot man
cool shot
[Music]
the world sure seems different from down
here doesn't it sky what it's a trial by
fire Scott or in this case water
[Music]
guess you're tougher than you thought
[Music]
alright alright alright it was pretty
cool I'm the effects definitely don't
look that bad they look pretty good man
I I like what he shrunk down in that job
when I was soo min in on am stringing
that was a cool shot I like the tone
they have going on it looks pretty funny
I am he's like zipping through the water
and all that I like those little details
like cuz I know this suit when he's
small get some super strength so when he
flew out of the bathtub the part of the
floor cracked a little bit I wonder if
that's gonna get notice that all the
reference at all I want to know why
Michael Payne your turn on the bath
what's he going to shower is Paul Rudd
gonna see Michael Pena's penis will we
see Michael Pena's penis in the new
Marvel film I'm a little bit lost in
this sense of Hank Michael Douglas's
character one would assume that he would
tell him what this suit is and how it
works before giving it to him so I was
like how come now he's sort of learning
it seems like this was the first time he
was discovering that oh my god this suit
makes you tiny when he crashed on the
floor I let me just see this yeah I'm
pretty sure there's a pubic hair in this
video a pubic my pubes look like that
and I'm pretty sure that's a pubic hair
I got curly dark pubic hair that looks
like a curly dark future yeah I'll take
a picture for you guys you guys see that
pubic hair to the lower right of the
screen yeah
you guys want to know my balls kind of
looked like it they look like hairs like
that just that long - yeah I know the
effects look good it looks like there's
a good sense of humor about it I feel
like it's gonna be fun when he's
figuring out the suit but I don't know
dick kind of seemed random when Michael
Pena is sort of walked in the apartment
and then he immediately goes to the
bathtub and just turns it on and he's
like not even addressing I don't even
think he closed the door but whatever
little details like that anyway guys
thanks for saying that was out it is
8:00 in the morning right now I woke up
at 7:00 to edit so thank you guys cuz
this is making my morning a little bit
better if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter and vine where if we get enough
followers we can get more product
placement
Anthony Chabot is this where we send
shoutouts yes it is my friend you have
found the facebook.com/ shout out page
anyway Anthony Chavez Anthony's actually
my brother's name Anthony he'd be kind
of a dick sometimes you know like he
used to punch me a lot growing up he
stood his thing where if I even touched
him a little bit like on the arm he
would like wipe himself as if I was a
germ why do you do this to me Anthony
Anthony Shabbos you son of a [ __ ] your
name's Anthony there must be just like
him you [ __ ]